if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
dump big massive dumpsters times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to sea
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm gonna have to cut it early
because i just have too much to get to
today
too much to talk about it's a big big
day what's up with my graphics
where where are my graphics
it's all oh there they are that was
weird uh welcome everybody
uh i have everything from um
jimmy from philly videos to
produce fruit and vegetable questions
today
um i'll just get right into it
first things first right before we went
to uh spring when we went on spring
break
we had a poll on the david pakman show
community page who's your favorite
regular caller
and jimmy from philly1 over the eggman
pedro from colombia
san antonio troll and kansas troll and i
guess jimmy from philly found out about
it but he still hasn't figured out that
the voicemail number he's been calling
has been disconnected for two months
it's really weird check this out jimmy
from philly
wiped so
one of my trolls told me that uh
i want a poll on pacman's uh
youtube if you go to david pakman
and go to your community tab and pack
and put up a poll and say who's your
favorite regular calling
to the show rugged your caller of course
i won by 39
it's like no you didn't win by 39 you
won by 19.
oh that's funny that is funny and let's
face it i haven't called the show
since uh since
uh and four black fellas took my trump
signs
of which i i did beat that case too but
uh
that that that that's kind of funny this
is a poll he believes because he wanted
yeah beaut
nicely done juxta junk saint beautifully
done
that's kind of funny oh and another
thing uh
i don't know how you people feel about
it but uh
i am not getting the jab it's just not
gonna happen first
all right he's so anyway he's going into
anti-vaxx anyway so he did win
later in the in the video he says that
the voicemail number is always busy
like it's not busy jimmy you're just
calling a number we haven't used for a
long time the
the only voicemail number now is 2192
davidp
he's calling the old call-in number so
there's jimmy from philly
okay here's a produce question i bought
this for this is not a granny smith
apple
okay i bought this today at the grocery
store it was
labeled an ecuadorian dragon fruit i'm
into trying different dragon fruits but
when i went to the cash register
the nice young lady rung it up as a
guava
do i look like i was trying to buy guava
okay so can somebody tell me what this
is is this a guava or
or is it a an ecuadorian dragon fruit
it's not a granny smith look at the top
okay
doesn't really smell like anything
it's not guava it's guys it's not a
green tomato
it is a tropical fruit of some kind it's
either
a guava or an ecuadorian dragon fruit or
something else
it's not ripe i'm not gonna open it now
i'd be willing to unveil this
um on on uh on a future stream
oh god nobody knows people say it's a
tomato it's not a persimmon guys
it's not a persimmon all right well that
was a waste of time
anyway you can email me if you know what
kind of fruit that is
um super chat's coming in do you recall
your first meal
you ate upon arrival to the us from
argentina at eight five
at age five no i don't no i don't you
know what here's a funny story from
here's what i do remember from my
arrival from argentina
i knew like three or four words in
english i remember that at
jfk airport i was running around
and a woman said hello and i was like i
know that word
i'm one for one leaving the airport
the first thing i saw was a stop sign
and i was like
that's one of the words i know stop and
when i when that happened
i knew i've got this i'm going to be
able to learn english because i'm
recognizing
everything i'm running into looks like
an
unripe guava to me says wendy sunil says
it's a passion fruit
i don't think so how can we pass voting
rights legislation without scotus
striking it down
that's more of a topic for a youtube
clip so i'm not going to do that right
now
chakaseki says friendly psa beware of
borderline
illegal recurring donations to pakman
pak
known as pacman21 right
right chakaseki absolutely
i also want to say thank you to some
early twitch subscribers the wilhelm
screen
is now 16 months in caspa
is five months in also thanks to
addiseo skull
million and kim yoyo
that is five twitch subs right off the
bat very much appreciate that
honestly no joke at all today's
full episode of the david pakman show is
one of the best in a long time
if you were a website member in four
minutes
four minutes you would have access to
the following stories
my uh the offer i received
to become conservative and triple my
salary
a big time radio person came to me
and said you're good but there's no
money in being left wing
if you go right wing like have an
enlightenment
i could triple your salary for you okay
i tell that story today
on the bone on the broadcast show which
you could have access to
in four minutes if you were a member
okay because this goes live for members
in
in four minutes that's going to be a
weekend story otherwise
and um wait what else what was on
today's show
oh oh oh oh i did an interview
people asked and i delivered people said
david interview a republican
go and argue with a republican the way
you used to do i did it it's kind of
cringe
okay that's on today's broadcast show
as a member you would get access three
minutes from now
otherwise you're gonna have to wait
hours to days okay maybe i'll preview a
little bit of this
and we also did a um
what else did we do today it's just a
great show
i i feel really strongly about about
today's show all right
so that's that uh google green guava
green guava
images yeah that's this guys
this this looks like this that looks
like what i have
this was labeled as an ecuadorian dragon
fruit
and i went with it oh that looks nice
though look at the inside
that is nice
all right i'm gonna wait for this to be
ripe and maybe i'll open it on a stream
because that looks pretty nice that's
not bad
i'll go back and try to get the
ecuadorian dragon fruit we'll try to
sort out
what that was okay so hold on i can
close this and this
okay
wonder if that guy was responsible for
reuben's classical liberal enlightenment
no no no no
he's not that's something different
uh okay unban requests on twitch
none so that's done nothing there
uh okay what else oh you know what let's
let's
do a little bit of it let's look here's
here's a preview
here's like this will be a good
membership pitch if you don't want to
wait days for this full interview
here's where the topic of vaccines came
up with republican strategist
amanda mackey all right let's you guys
asked for this you said start
interviewing republicans again
united states at the end of his term
there were two vaccines on the market
which i have always said having you know
worked in health care policy as a health
care attorney i mean that's nothing
short of nobel peace prize winning and
you can't say that it's not
now you can't just say that was all
president trump but certainly pushing on
all the levers to get that to market
he said that during the campaign season
and people laughed at him people
mocked him and said there's no way he's
just lying
and in december we were vaccinating
people well but
let's break that down a little bit
though because there's a bunch of pieces
there so
okay um yes trump certainly funded
uh the manufacturer of vaccines and he
pre-pre did the pre-purchasing of
vaccines on spec
before we even knew whether these
vaccines were going to be approved
that's that's good any any president
would do that i mean to give him
too much credit for that seems a little
strange but when you think about
the the trajectory there were people
saying
december it's never going to happen in
may
goldman sachs put out to the month
an accurate prediction saying based on
the research that's being done around
the world
we expect healthcare workers to start
being vaccinated in in november
and here's where i really am curious
like what exactly you think trump did on
vaccination because
the pfizer vaccine was developed by
turkish immigrants to germany
the moderna vaccine was sequenced before
donald trump
even knew what was going on with the
pandemic
uh so i'm like what exactly did trump do
on the vaccines maybe we can figure it
out
well i think just pushing on every lever
of the government to get that domain
operation warp speed even um
you know even dr fauci's boss
dr francis collins of the nih has said
that
operation work speed deserves a lot of
this gets much worse just so you guys
just prepare
and so i think when you have a ceo which
obviously he was for many years um as
president you know there is just uh
i think he had just the line of sight to
make sure that this happens
listen line of sight pushing levers and
you can say that you know well this was
all in the works well mrnas have been
studied for a decade so yes
i mean technically pharmaceuticals are
always in the works
um but you know pushing that through to
happen in december
no one believed that but what did he do
to push him
for that who did he push though what did
he push
well i can't say exactly what he pushed
it didn't work in the trump
administration
what i can say is that when he said
every day we're working through
operation warp speed
um to get this done uh you know
everything that comes together
through the government whether it's
lifting uh
regulations or making it easier to get
through
the chambers of government i worked in
congress for
you know a decade and it's not easy to
just get through a very
clunky federal government and
bureaucratic system but amanda what what
regulations completely resulted in
vaccines
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to give me something specific because so
far you said you don't actually know but
trump said he was working hard which
often means watching fox news
and tweeting what what what regulations
were lifted to make this happen more
quickly
look verbal inkblot what she's giving us
again i'm not going to give specifics
because i don't know exactly what he did
and he never said what he did right so
you don't know he did anything
i'm sorry you can't really say he did
anything then i think that's absolutely
false
now you can look back and say well he
said this or he said that and that
wasn't true
but what the ultimate result was these
vaccines
coming to market i don't think you can
deny that
deny which part that the vaccines were
were made
that the the vaccines were made in
record time
in record time they were made and i i am
sure
that there are regulations that were
lifted there were things within the
government that were done
by this administration to ensure that
that happened
uh with record speed i mean usually it
takes a decade
not for mrna vaccines and therapeutics
to come to market not for mrna vaccines
all right
let's move on amanda because so anyway
let's see if we can find like one other
thing
um let me see here
here's something on the this is
uncovered relief it also was basically
just as haywire
remember you guys asked for this i don't
need to be
i'm fine just doing my commentaries
people said talk to republicans
listen i mean he didn't pay attention to
a single
one of their interests and it sounds
like staff was involved in this
yeah so the point is if you want to look
back on president trump he passed
five coronavirus bills with bipartisan
support
and president biden didn't do that with
bipartisan support but amanda that's
that's an indictment of republicans
that's in that's an indict the fact
you're absolutely right
when it was trump saying we we have to
get money to businesses and the american
people
democrats didn't say we are going to
deny this to trump merely because he's
in the other party because the american
people need it
when democrats said okay well now it's
us we'll do a relief bill that's very
similar to what trump did
republicans said we're not participating
and also what what you've just said is
arguably the biggest
indictment of the obstructionist
republicans that i can imagine
misinterpreting what i
said no i don't think so using your own
facts because what i said is that the
republicans went to visit with president
biden yeah
and he dismissed everything that they
said he didn't take a single thing into
account he didn't even work with them
he didn't even come to the table and say
let's sit down and talk
what concessions did trump make to
democrats he largely blamed it on staff
as did republicans the staff saying
we're not interested but what
concessions did trump make to democrats
on the coveted bills
uh kennedy center funding uh certainly
other
pieces of the of the bill that
ultimately the law that republicans were
raped over the coals for
kennedy center wasn't that like 3
million bucks or something
it doesn't matter it's the fact that you
know this is what's interesting to me
yeah president uh trump was impeached
by the house and then three months later
he has nancy pelosi sit down with anyway
so i'm not gonna play the whole thing
but that goes on for 20 minutes that was
by popular demand people saying david
interview some republicans so i did it
if you sign up for a membership you
would have access to that full interview
right now because we've already put it
out for our members otherwise
someday someday it'll be out all right
guys and i do want to say thank you but
speaking of memberships
ryan benson just signed up at
joinpackman.com
dylan tinetti just signed up at
joinpacman.com
brentwilliams just signed up at
jointpakman.com
jacob young just signed up at
jointpakman.com that's four people
most of them using the secret
unpublished coupon code
immoral21 immoral 21 is the secret
coupon code you might say david i don't
know it says better21
that's right that's right because um
it's a secret coupon code immoral 21.
so that's good uh oh update do you guys
want a bongo meme
update or do you want um
a sake bomb uh steve peter ducey
collapsed today
figuratively of course during a uh
during a press briefing while you guys
decide i want to say thanks to
sheila key stitch for the twitch sub
that's it actually just that's the only
one
super chats if trump did anything she'd
know it we all would yeah i know
fool in the rain says david on the bonus
several weeks ago you talked about latin
x have you heard of
gender neutral neutral folks i don't
understand how we can make an already
gender-neutral word more gender-neutral
i haven't heard of folks
as a hispanic male myself i don't use
latinx
i use uh i don't use it and we've we've
talked about it already
okay very good
stephen hart says david did you see the
new clip on right wing watches twitter
about how coveted nasal schwabs are
going to turn us into flesh-eating
zombies
no if can someone email me that clip
i'll cover it on the show tomorrow if
someone can email me
covet nasal schwabs will turn us into
flesh-eating zombies
i will cover that on tomorrow's show
let's do
uh bongos this is the new um
the new contest i have 10 memberships to
give away for
show related remix excuse me remixes of
this
video
[Laughter]
okay so we have some submissions i
showed you yesterday here is the newest
one
this is the newest submission
so i guess the the thing is here this is
one of those games like what dance dance
revolution or like nintendo wii type
[Music]
games
that's the concept here's another one
this is a good one people found this one
a little disturbing yesterday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right that's another submission
here's one from shiro
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay and then uh here's one more
primer
i love the poorly educated
i don't totally get this one but then i
think it's towards the end
i pop up real quick enjoy yourself
like overall i think the first 44
seconds are flat
but then the last three where i gavel
into an explosion
is pretty good yourself there it is
and then here was the first submission
we received
[Applause]
[Applause]
guess what i got a fever
and the only prescription is more
cowbell
it was a perfect storm really
welcome to san francisco mr bukowski
[Music]
again i think the only funny part of
this one is me with the gavel
[Music]
and our yeah oh these people don't know
what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second so
those are the five submissions so far
i have ten memberships to give away so
so far it's like everybody's gonna get a
membership
get yours in ideally do youtube
uploads and then send me the youtube
link that's the best way to go
a few other new members to announce and
welcome danielle
butler just signed up at
joinedpakman.com danielle thank you
perfect membership
yitzhak gordon new member
uh at joinpakman.com thank you yitzhak
and also don sharp signing up at
joinpakman.com putting us
at 13. lastly uh thanks to chief boris
double07
for signing up via twitch very very much
appreciate that um oh sorry guys hold on
a second i need to ban
someone ban hammer on twitch you're not
gonna get anti-semitic stuff by me in
spanish
uh someone just sent a spanish message
the spam filter caught it
saying uh you're a shitty jew son of a
[ __ ]
and you deserve colon cancer son of a
[ __ ] they've been banned
uh the message didn't even get through
that's sad really really sad
okay um
rudd says your bongos contest has sent
me into a youtube spiral long story
short i now know
almost all the words to the original
lavon polka song
i don't speak finnish at all
bongo remix idea to talented folks put
cat trump biden
into beat saver background plus david
with squeaky gavel
i don't know what any of those things
mean thoughts on stephen crowder's
banning
where has crowder been banned i don't
even know about stephen crowder being
banned
tells you how much i'm aware of his
online presence where was he banned from
anybody know
on youtube supposedly he's not banned
some people are saying
suspended okay get his tweets removed
i don't know i mean uh do you guys
remember that moment where
i pretended not to know crowder thinks
of himself as a comedian let me see if i
can find it
joe rogan pacman crowder
um let me see here
joe rogan
let's see if this is it i don't know
see if i can find it the jurgen
experience
that's the thing right it's like are you
responsible
for the people who also comment on your
post
and this is this is where this is a 26
minute i don't know if i'm gonna be able
to find the moment
if someone can just tell me the time
code in this clip
joe rogan reacts to youtube demonetizing
crowder where rogan
explains to me that um crowder is a
comedian
i'll come back to it but it's a 20 we
just don't have time for a 26 minute
clip because we're up against a major
announcement from joseph r biden jr
about uh another two week advance
on wide open vaccination wide wide open
okay so we're caught up on
super chats which is great
will i do a hot tub stream i don't even
know what that means i don't i don't
have a hot tub
thanks to cybrid for the twitch sub you
are number 15. very much appreciate that
would i open phone lines yeah yeah if we
get to 100 members or twitch subs we're
only 85 away
i'll open phone lines right after the
biden event and
uh somebody could just dump in 85 gifted
subs
or we could do it one by one but yeah no
i'm more than willing to open up phone
lines
david if you had to pick between
approval ranked choice voting or another
kind of voting system would which would
you pick
i'm fi i'm a sort of a leaning towards
single transferable vote and i've got a
bunch of youtube clips about this
many many youtube clips check those out
maria curcola has just signed up at
joinpakman.com and is new member number
16.
here is um
oh yeah check this out
check check this out uh this is um steve
peter ducey
trying to you know do something and it
doesn't go well
is the white house concerned that major
league baseball is moving their all-star
game to colorado where
voting regulations are very similar to
georgia
well let me just refer the few refute
the first point you made first let me
say
on colorado colorado uh
allows you to register on election day
colorado has
voting by mail where they send to 100 of
people on the state
who are eligible applications to vote by
mail 94
of people in colorado voted by mail in
the 2020
election and they also allow for
a range of materials to provide
even if they vote on election day for
the limited number of people who
who vote on election day i think it's
important to remember the context here
uh
the georgia legislation is built on a
lie
uh it's there was no why so anyway you
know he tries to pull a gotcha type game
with jen
saki and she anticipated it and was
prepared and on the show tomorrow
it's actually there's actually way more
uh substantive difference between the
law
in colorado and the law in georgia now
it's true that if the law was the same
in georgia and colorado and you just
moved the all-star game from georgia to
colorado it would be kind of stupid
the the idea is a good one he's just
wrong on the facts
very very wrong completely and we'll go
into detail about that tomorrow
um and then lastly here is fox news
very much against cancellations running
a scroll of businesses they want to
cancel
let's look at the list other companies
and organizations that have criticized
the georgia voting laws they're not
saying that they're boycotting but
they're criticizing
and that's where these things some fox
news is naming names
times can start i say sometimes we can't
tell the future look at this list
from what what you're saying atlanta
all of georgia can be hurt by these
decisions and i want to point out
who did their homework on denver who did
their homework on colorado compare the
voter laws is their id requirements
let's look at so anyway same same stupid
stuff on fox news
going on we'll have coverage of that the
swirl experience just asked via
a really really strong super chat david
why haven't you discussed the matt gates
scandal
we were on vacation when the scandal
broke and i find that
it doesn't really make sense to like go
back and cover old news when we get back
from break
but today we did cover matt gates
because
child sex trafficking does carry a
potential life in prison
sentence so we talked about like what
he's actually up against and i kind of
refreshed the entire story on today's
podcast again
if you are a member you already have
access to today's full show with all of
this stuff on it
otherwise the clip will be out um later
today
thanks to justin hannah for subscribing
at joinedpakman.com
thanks to andre ruth for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
thanks to teresa durkee as well as our
newest member
nancy bernhard este all of whom just
grabbed
perfect memberships at joinedpakman.com
also want to say thank you to auntie
ulicha
as well as akira loves ruji
mtdts kion
pepper all who just grabbed memberships
at joinpackman.com
thanks thank you very much
uh yeah and there's also you know like i
got a few emails from people implying
that there was some reason i was
deliberately not covering
the uh matt gates scandal like why
why why wouldn't i wouldn't i cover that
so why are we even here today
we are here because joe biden is about
to
he's expected to announce that even
though he has already moved up the date
at which
everyone becomes eligible for a vaccine
to may 1st
he is going to move it up an additional
let me see how much
would this be may 1
what month is it oh it's april he's
going to move it up an additional
almost two weeks to april 19th
april 19th we are expecting
everybody will be eligible vaccinations
are
highly explosive right now as you can
see here we now
are averaging 3.05
million doses per day about one percent
of the american
population is getting um
a dose every single day we are starting
to see
cases turn back around after this just a
little bump that took place they're
coming back down
deaths fortunately continue to go to go
down
i believe that by memorial day may 31st
we are going to have
significantly better looking numbers
than we have right now so the
announcement we're expecting
momentarily from joe biden is moving up
by about an additional
11 or 12 days the date at which
everyone will become 16 plus will become
eligible for a vaccine
uh fenugrengler is telling me that i
mispronounced their name
yesterday i apologize for that i didn't
mean to do that
uh okay
and oh hold on i'm being told that i do
have
some ban unban request adjudications to
do
no i don't see any i don't believe i do
i'm not seeing any guys yeah
um the person i just uh
banned for the spanish anti-semitism has
not requested an unban
they seem to know that they're not
getting one
yeah so that's not uh that's not going
to happen okay
did anybody i'm sorry did anybody find
the time code
of the crowder as a comedian moment in
this clip
i think i missed it if someone sent it
to me i was trying to find the moment
where i pretend not to know
that crowder is a community supposedly a
comedian
anybody
nobody knows i could have sworn it went
by and now i can't find it in the chat
i got moderna for people asking me which
vaccine i got
yeah uh so yesterday yesterday's bonus
show
i i actually think i you know i wasn't
joking
yesterday's bonus show is the i think
it's the most watched bonus
it's at 7 30. okay we'll go in a second
yesterday's bonus show
is the most watched bonus show i believe
we've ever had
i tell the story of my run-ins during
spring
spring break with anti-masters with a
deep
nose swab and a whole bunch of other
stuff all right let's listen
yes that's fundamentally what it is but
as a company they have a left-wing virus
i don't know that in what sense
well in the sense that the woman is the
ceo of youtube
has talked about it pretty openly like
the fact that she doesn't
what was it that she had gotten into
what she oh well first of all it was the
the james is it
i mean i started at 7 30. did is
is this the right uh it doesn't seem
like that's what the let's see it's the
more thing
you know she was talking about the
google memo and she was talking about
how
it was uh yeah other people are telling
me it's way way after this
yeah i don't know why everyone's saying
it's 7 30.
that was the 7 30 moment
is there another time code i could try
oh different clip well i said in this
clip which clip is it in
1340 now someone says let's see
everyone should have the freedom of
expression and that as long as you're
not doing anything
illegal you're not putting anyone into
danger by giving up their address or
doxxing them or something along those
lines or making overt physical threats
right
that you should be allowed to do that
because that's what the freedom of the
speech
is all about and freedom of speech when
you eliminate
social media in this country is you're
you're you're not here
basically just yelling yelling out in
public i mean you're you're
we're in this weird place it's always a
culture as a culture it's
all right so it's it's not there
it's just not there
like is it even that funny to give me
the wrong time codes i don't know
yeah it's frustrating i agree i agree no
we're still waiting for joe biden
nobody's missed anything if you're just
joining us
so listen guys the clip is joe rogan
reacts to youtube demonetizing stephen
crowder
uh 17 40. all right
let's try seventeen see what i'm saying
it's it's a sneaky kind of regulation
it's a regulation that's
enforcing the first amendment and the
people's ability to freely express
themselves
if we're admitting or if we're agreeing
that we are entering into this new world
yes where this
that's my position is it is a town
square and i feel like everybody should
be
able to communicate the really
unfortunate
unsavory aspect of it is when someone
gets harassed
like carlos meza was because of this
where people are sending him all these
homophobic
tweets and all this i mean he's getting
text messages and all this [ __ ]
that's that's the unsavory and
unfortunate aspect of it
and how do you stop all right so that's
not it either
that's not it either i don't know uh i
don't need anybody sending me a link
just tell me what the time code is
people posting links like crazy
uh this is it just happened we just went
through 1750.
yeah all right well thanks chad
i guess i guess it's it's just not it's
not going to work
people give me the wrong time code i
want to say thanks to laurie
cadetsony for subscribing at
joinpackman.com
and bertha macias at joinpackman.com
we continue to see a trend where
overall like all shows like mine
are our membership and our viewership
skus mail
but in terms of people who sign up for
memberships during live streams
it's overwhelmingly women it's crazy
other than stephen coffer
who just signed up in his new member
number 27.
also want to say thanks to darasim
nebulin
for subscribing via twitch very much
appreciate that
denver mccarthy says david i got the jnj
vaccine
and my david pakman mug today can you
imagine that's great to hear yeah we
actually
we turned off all apparel sales on our
website during
uh the virus beca because
um the fulfillment was just off the off
the wall
the manufacturers of our stuff were
closed then they would ship
it and the shipping would take four
weeks we basically i basically became a
shipping clerk
so we shut it all down it's all back
open and i'm glad to hear people are
getting their mugs
and all of their all of their different
stuff
great to hear great to hear and oh oh oh
that's right we have a new logo so the
logo down here is the one that's still
on all of our apparel
the logo back there is the new logo
we're in the process
of updating all apparel to have the new
logo
so you are at some point no longer going
to be able to get the old gear
they'll all in a sense they'll be like
collectors items so that's exciting
big thank you to guitar goddess goddess
for gifting 10 subs
and signing back up herself that's 10
plus 1 is 11
11 plus 28 8 plus 1 is 9 3 plus 1
39 putting us at a
really really great number um
man this user j the truth is pasting
links
like 20 times and the links are blocked
on twitch
so i don't know what is going on with
that
can a moderator maybe send me the link
or something i mean
it can't be this tough to just figure
out where i mean it's like at this point
it's no longer even funny when i pretend
not to know stephen crowder is a
comedian
dan crenshaw said he would go on the
record that he's impressed by joe biden
if he could get 200 million americans
vaccinated in a hundred days it may
happen
it may happen okay 21.05
21.05 let's see here
2105. i believe a lot of weird things
and want other people to conform to
those weird things
and we sort of have to decide like
that's why i'm bringing up this crowder
thing like
do i think that what he said was good no
it's not nice to call someone a
little less be queer it's not nice it's
kind of mean you know and
especially when that guy wasn't even
engaging with him but he's making fun of
him he's a comedy show he's mocking them
so the question becomes like when
when is that mocking considered
homophobic and when is it just
ribbing right and that's his position
his position is that it's just ribbing
this is the problem with a discussion
that is only about
the principles so like a lot of our
conversation for the last 15 minutes has
been
what is our principle about what types
of
business regulation is okay for the
government to do
and is not okay or when we talk about
free speech
what should do we have a principle of
anything short of illegal content
versus something that is more strict the
reality is that
it's a there's a more gray area yeah
we're trying to
sort of regulate the way people
communicate with each other
so it's it's not it's like if someone
said that to someone in a bar
a cop would not is my reaction coming up
rest them
like yeah you listen be a little queer
you know that would be like oh that
guy's an [ __ ] but the bar would be
perfectly within their legal right to
say we don't we don't want you in here
you're making our customers
uncomfortable and nobody would say that
it would be
against the law for the bar to say you
got gotta go that's a good point if they
were doing it
to their face but what if he was in a
corner talking about this guy
that wasn't there and he was saying yeah
so he's talking about antifa this lispy
little mexican queer
if you came along and decided to kick
the guy out of the bar then
it would i mean listen at some bars if
you go into the corner and you yell
about a lispy
mexican queer they're going to ask you
to leave and it still would not be
illegal and the bar would still not be
doing anything right but that's a bar
right that's a private business where
people are physically there yes
isn't there a difference between that
and something like youtube which again
falls more in line with like a town
square
maybe that's what we need to revisit
because so much human communication is
now happening across these platforms i
would imagine
most of it or most of it we need to
maybe stop
drawing this arbitrary distinction that
in person
is a completely different thing over the
internet i mean maybe it's not
increasingly maybe it's more
the same yeah um
so i'm torn here right on one side i say
well
all right the jo the joke maybe was
before let's let's go back a little bit
people ability to censor based on their
political ideology or based on what they
feel is offensive or other people don't
it's a slippery slope
and i think that that can that can lead
to
all sorts look that woman what is her
name again
the one who tried to get her amy siskind
imagine her
being in charge of a social media
platform she tried to get you fired from
boston college for something that was
incredibly polite
right that is what i'm talking about is
that very action that very same type of
thinking
that she tried to impose on you that's
what i'm worried about well and they're
worried about people that are really
strictly trying
yeah all right you know what it's like
this was 20 minutes ago anyway we've all
i think most people don't even know what
i'm looking for now so
we're gonna we're just gonna get off of
it i'm i'm officially calling
the the search over for that
the search is over um
yeah okay all right good thank you to
simone
bean for signing up at joinpackman.com
thank you to mark
frankum for signing up at
joinedpakman.com thanks to
craig neblet for the membership
thank you to austin skoog as well as
greta
hoxie five new members at joinpakman.com
very much appreciate that and yes uh
phone lines will open if we get to a
hundred
or and or if we get to a thousand
twitch subs
david at this point you may as well have
watched the whole podcast yeah i should
have just started at the beginning of
the three hour episode with rogan and
watched the whole thing i probably would
have found it
by now that's true a couple people are
asking for more
clips from the right the republican i
interviewed today all right
i'd look at another clip let me see if i
can find it real quick
um by popular demand
i interviewed a republican
strategist today and i looked at a
couple of clips
earlier some of you found them
frustrating
uh let's look at another section here
um i don't know let's just pick it up
somewhere in the middle
and see what's going on we've debunked
so
we because we i've debunked that
extensively i don't want to
jump into that um uh so so let's not
jump into that
in the few minutes we have left what is
the
policy right now that you think
republicans
should be focusing on what policy now i
know you're saying
well they don't control anything right
now okay fine but when trump controlled
everything
you still had democrats proposing things
and saying this is what we would like to
see
what are the main policy points you
think would be advantageous to the
republican party right now to be working
on
well the republican party can't work on
anything right now
it would have been nice if the democrats
propose an actual infrastructure bill
because
as you know infrastructure is a key word
for bipartisanship where do they all
have the exact same talking points
right but when you have a bill that's
introduced that even democrats can't
agree on uh where
the majority of it is not for actual
roads and bridges
but this isn't my question i'm sorry
i i didn't ask anything i'm just saying
what should be the policy priorities of
republicans
well if if republicans were in control
um i think that uh lowering health care
costs
should be an important uh demonstration
of their uh
of their efforts to help americans uh
especially after the last year americans
have consumed a lot of health care
so making sure that you know whether
it's deductibles out-of-pocket costs are
are not uh prohibitively expensive for
americans and certainly making sure drug
costs come down
i think you can work in a bipartisan way
on that um look i know immigration is
the third rail of politics
but we we have got to re-visit
our immigration policies um when you ha
you know our immigration policies are
tailored towards the 1990s mentality
of while you have people coming from
central america and mexico
to the united states to work adults you
don't have
seven-year-olds walking over by
themselves you don't have these coyotes
you know dropping these kids over the
fence that's the new normal
uh in our immigration and if republicans
and democrats don't tackle this
uh that's going to have a huge impact on
the united states and workers in the
united states we still have high
unemployment numbers
and if we're allowing mass migration to
happen um and not doing anything to
enforce the borders we're going to have
problems in all 50 states
so so health care and immigration would
be your priorities if republicans could
get things done right now
i think they just need to sit down and
reevaluate the situation i mean what's
happening right now is that you have
coyotes bringing children
anyway it was a lot of like you know
just kind of
going on and on um so i don't know
you know people said i should do more of
those and so we did one
i i don't know that we learn it's like
she i've already reported on all these
bullet points like we already debunked
we talked about the seasonality of of
people coming over the border
we talked about the absurdity of saying
most of the infrastructure proposal
isn't about infrastructure
like i can't debunk at all in that
setting
and so i just don't know like yeah
they're using the talking points we know
for people asking for a link to that
interview
if you are a member hello
it's on the member portal right now if
you're not there is no link yet because
we've not published it yet
all right so that's that
super chat's coming in steven says same
for most right-wingers no understanding
of economics history geopolitics or
social issues just regurgitating talking
points it's quite sad
yeah that's basically what the interview
was i mean it was kind of just i don't
know like is it worth
us scheduling the interview and
just to then do that where it's like
yeah we've already pre-debunked all of
those talking points in segments
you guys tell me like i'm glad to do it
it's sort of fun in a way
the interviews get spread and your
arguments convince the other side
i don't know that that's the case
i genuinely don't know if that's
actually going on
i'm open to that idea i'm open to that
idea
uh but i just i just am not i'm just not
sure about that
if it were the case i would be doing a
lot more of it yeah that's for sure
it's worth it because nobody else
challenges them i
i guess i don't know david chadman says
dunk on her harder next time
i don't know i don't know it's worth
doing them if you can get a gotcha
moment i mean i think here the gacha
moment was where she just like admitted
she couldn't
name anything about vaccines right uh it
was like right around here regulations
that were lifted there were things
within the government that were done by
this administration to ensure that that
happen
uh with record speed i mean usually it
takes a decade
not for mrna vaccines and therapeutics
to come to market not for mrna vaccines
all right let's move on amanda because
i do have other things i want to talk
about but if at some point there's
something specific
you can tell me you know trump did
rather than just he was claiming that he
was doing stuff we will we will report
it
about claiming i mean even when the nih
head
like i said who is dr fauci's boss said
operation warp speed deserves credit
he didn't say pfizer deserves credit he
said operation warp speed
operation warp speed was a function of
the trump administration
yes now the two vaccines that were first
approved
weren't part of it they did purchase
vaccines
but uh fine okay good so yeah okay
good so anyway that's that i don't know
we'll see if we'll see if we do more of
it or not
oh we're standing by for joe biden he's
now 23 minutes late but we are standing
by for it other super chats coming
in uh was the girl in the interview you
just played using a green screen
yes she was yes she was
christian says hey david i was wondering
if you heard about local elections
coming up within the next month or so in
fort worth we have an important mayoral
seat texas six to replace the late ron
wright
who died from covet in january um no i
i'm not i don't know what's going on
with uh fort worth mayoral i
i admit and i i will check into that
other race
a lot to keep up with will we have herd
immunity by early may no i don't think
we'll have heard immunity by early may
but i think we will have
more than enough vaccination at that
point that cases
will be going down significantly fool in
the rain says i think in the viewing
republicans is import interviewing i
guess they mean
republicans is important because it may
convince some who are on the fence
it's possible it's possible yeah
um i i don't i don't know you know as i
said before
for better and worse these types of
interviews are basically
just exercises in rhetoric
you know like the you're not really
going to get in a 20-minute interview
all of the facts out and a full hearing
of the facts it's basically just an
exercise in rhetoric
i was prepared for the tired talking
points she would present
she didn't have anything better or
different to present
and so the outcome is sort of
predictable
um but it's really an exercise in
rhetoric rather than an evaluation of
the data
in a sense and and so you know i've
talked with
vaush about that on the program before
and make of it make it what you will to
some degree it's valuable to some degree
i question uh i question the value of it
okay we are standing by for president
joe biden who is going to give us
what we believe is going to be an
announcement that he is moving
up full eligibility for covet vaccines
from may 1st to april 19th
that's going to be about 10 11 12 days
sooner
than previously announced which was
already an exciting date may 1st
vaccine rollout continues to accelerate
and it's a good thing it's a very very
good thing let's see if anybody else is
live yet not quite yet
but it looks like this will be starting
soon the sign language
uh translator is is this is sign
language is it called a translation when
you're going from
english to american sign language or is
it interpretation
anybody know
no sounds like someone's walking up here
it's an interpreter here we go beautiful
outside we should be doing this outside
[Music]
good afternoon everyone i just visited a
vaccination
clinic in virginia at the virginia
theological seminary in alexandria
virginia
the seminary and other houses of worship
in the area are
partnering with the community health
centers
to offer vaccinations and vaccination
sites
they're seeing these kinds of
partnerships we're and not just there
but we're seeing them all over the
country
people are coming together across
different faiths to serve those
most in need with special focus on
vaccinating seniors
from all races backgrounds and walks of
life
it's an example of america at its finest
and they're all meeting what pope
francis calls the moral obligation
get vaccinated something which can he
went on to say
can save your life and the lives of
others
and i was at the seminary clinic to mark
an important milestone as well
yesterday we crossed 150 million
shots wow in 75 days the first 75 days
of my administration
strong on our way to hitting our goal of
200 million shots
by the 100th day in office nice that of
course
is the new goal i said after passing the
original mark of 100 million shots in my
first 100 days
doing that in just 58 days at the time
some said 100 million shots was too
ambitious
and then they said it wasn't ambitious
enough well we got to keep moving if we
could raise it up higher i'd do that as
well but we know
we know we have to do we have to ramp up
a whole government approach
that rallies the whole country and puts
us on a war footing to truly beat this
virus
and that's what we've been doing getting
enough vaccine supply
mobilizing more vaccinators creating
more places to get vaccinated
and we're now administering an average
of 3 million
shots per day over 20 million shots a
week
on saturday alone we reported more than
4 million shots were administered we're
the first country to administer 150
million shots in the first country
to fully vaccinate over 62 million
people
but here's the deal i promise an update
to the american people every 50
millionth shot
and i'm already back to update you a
little over
two weeks two and a half weeks later
beautiful i promise in the beginning
that i'd always give you the straight
scoop straight from the shoulder
the good and the bad well here's the
truth
the good news is we're on track to beat
our goal of 200 million shots in the
first hundred days
more than 75 percent of the people
over the age of 65 have gotten shots
up from eight percent when we took
office
that's a dramatic turnaround and
critical
because seniors account for 80 percent
of all kova deaths
to help support my goal of safely
opening the majority of k-8
schools by my 100th day in office i
directed states
in early march to make educators and
children
child care workers eligible for vaccines
and to get a goal of getting all who
wanted the vaccination
to be able to have one and to do it in
the month of march
i'm pleased to report according to cdc
estimates over 80 percent of teachers
school child school staff and child care
workers received at least
one shot by the end of march that's
great progress protecting our educators
our essential workers
and because our vaccine program is an
overdrive
we're making it easier to get a
vaccination shot
last week i announced that by april 19th
of this month
90 of all americans will be within
five miles of a vaccination site
and further good news is that we're
getting more and more data
on just how effective the vaccines are
dr fauci recently cited two studies from
the new england journal of medicine
that found fully vaccinated care workers
health care workers
on the front lines had extremely low
infection rates
less than two tenths of one percent
compared incredibly vaccinated health
care workers incredible numbers
higher infection rates so we're making
incredible progress
there's a lot of good news but there's
also some bad news
new new variants of the virus
are spreading and they're moving quickly
cases are going back up hospitalizations
are no longer declining
while deaths are still down way down
from january
they're going up in some places so you
might ask
everybody's asking what does that mean i
understand that people may find it
confusing
that the vaccination program is saving
tens of thousands of lives but the
pandemic remains dangerous
let me explain it in a single word time
right time even moving at the record
speed removing that we're not
even halfway through vaccinating over
300 million americans
this is going to take time remember
for a two dose vaccine it takes
weeks from the time you get your first
one until you're able to get your
second shot right it makes you fully
protected
if you get your first shot next week in
mid-april
you won't be fully protected until until
may late may
late yeah get your first shot in midway
you aren't fully protected until late
june
so look now on the one hand
june isn't that far away given how long
this has been going on
but it isn't here yet either so
the virus is spreading because we have
too many people
who've seen the end in sight think we're
at the finish line already
but let me be deadly earnest with you we
aren't
at the finish line we still have a lot
of work to do
we're still in a life and death race
against this virus
until we get more people vaccinated we
need everyone to wash their hands
socially distance and mask up in a
recommended mass from the cdc
think about it this way better times are
ahead
as i said before we can have a safe
happy 4th of july
with your family and your friends and
small groups in your backyard
the real question is how much death
disease and misery
are we going to see between now and then
right
in january just the month of january we
lost
95 740
excuse me 95 774 americans
in march that was 37 thousand
172 americans all told
you all i keep doing this i know but i
carry this card every day with my
schedule on it
and the back i have a coveted update the
total number of deaths in the united
states to date
is 554 000.
64 dead very different than trump who
asked
not to even be told what the number is
that had been lost
what we do now was going to determine
how many people will
will save or lose in the month of april
and may and june
before we get to july 4th so please
until we're further along in this
accelerating
successful but still growing vaccination
effort
please wash your hands practice social
distancing
wear a mask as recommended by the cdc
get vaccinated when it's your turn
while i'm asking americans the american
people to do their jobs
here's what i'm doing right when we
first started our vaccination program
the real question is how quickly we can
get shots in people's arms
well by the end of may the vast majority
of dull americans
will have gotten at least their first
shot
that's success that success is going to
save lives
and get this country back to normal
sooner
but it's not enough on march the 11th
i announced that i was opening up all
vaccination sites
to all adults by may 1st here we go many
governors
democrats and republicans responded and
decided to beat that day which was good
thanks to their hard work and the hard
work of the american people
and the hard work of my team i'm
announcing today that we're moving that
date up from
may 1st to april 19th nationwide wow
that means by no later than april 19th
in every part of this country every
adult
over the age of 18 18 or older will be
eligible to be vaccinated
shots no more confusing rules
confusing restrictions 13 days to go my
message today is a simple one
many states have already opened up to
all adults right
but beginning april 19th every adult
in every state every adult in this
country is eligible to get in line
to get a covert vaccination beautiful
and today in advance of that new
national
full eligibility date i want to make a
direct appeal to our seniors
and everyone who cares about them while
we have made incredible progress
vaccinating three-quarters of our
seniors
and putting vaccination sites within
five miles of 90
of the public it still isn't enough
it's simple seniors
it's time for you to get vaccinated now
today
get vaccinated now to make it easier
my administration is sending aid to
community groups
to drive seniors to vaccination sites
we're incredibly grateful of all the
volunteers houses of worship
and civic groups that are helping us in
this effort
this is america we take care of one
another we have to keep it up
as we ask seniors to sign up for their
shots now
i also have a message of people under
65. yep
if you know someone over 65 has not
gotten this life-saving vaccine
call them now work with them to get
their shots
this week or next pick them up drive
them
it can be your parents your grandparents
your aunt uncle your neighbors
and finally even after you open up
vaccinations to all adults
and put a site within five miles of 90
of the public right we know there are
many people who still
struggle to get access to a shot or
don't want it we know that there are a
number of seniors and people with
disabilities
and people in many communities of color
who may
be isolated and lack access to
transportation
that's why we're ramping up
transportation to vaccination centers
and deploying more
mobile units and pop-up clinics in the
places
close to where i'm literally banning
anti-vaxxers as joe biden is announcing
this
and other community groups toast
vaccination clinics
sign people up for appointments get help
help them get those appointments that's
why we're sending even more
vaccines to community health centers
like the one i was in today
that all together serve nearly 30
million americans like the ones i
visited today
this is exciting enough that i may go
back and get a third vaccine
just just for kicks they're below the
poverty level
60 percent are racial and ethnic
minorities
to reach them we're investing nearly ten
billion dollars to expand
testing treatment and vaccinations for
the hardest hit
yet most underserved communities
let me close with this we vaccinated
more people than any other nation on
earth
the vaccines have proven to be safe and
effective
that should give us real hope but it
can't let it we can't let it make us
complacent
despite the progress we're making as a
nation i want every american to know
in no uncertain terms that this fight
isn't over
this progress we've worked so hard to
achieve can be reversed
now is not the time to let down
now is not the time to celebrate it's
time to do what we do best as a country
do our duty our jobs taking care of one
another
and we can and will do this but we
can't let up now my hope is
before the summer's over i'm talking to
you all about how we have even
access to more vaccines than we need
to take care of every american and we're
helping other poor countries
right countries around the world that
don't have the money the time the
expertise
because until this vaccine is available
to the world
and we're beating back the
vaccine the virus in other countries
we're not really completely safe
so we've made great progress
i'm still looking forward to the
prospect if we keep the pace we're on
and we listen to one another and
take the precautions i talked about that
you'd be able to have
a fourth of july an independence day
on july the 4th right as i defined about
three weeks ago i want to have an
independence day in independence from
the
covet so you're able to get in the
backyard with a small group of people of
friends and neighbors and celebrate
independence day
because you've been vaccinated because
you're safe
because you're in the clear may god
bless you all and may god protect our
troops thank you so much for listening
[Music]
i'll report on that dog later
should be moved out did you hear that i
think that's up to us that's steve
peterson
look asking about golf
you know kick them out
it is reassuring to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these news i'll give you the question in
a second guys are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move
out of georgia the people who need the
help the most
people who are making hourly wages
sometimes get hurt the most i think it's
a very tough decision for a corporation
to make
or a group to make but i respect them
when they make that judgment
dear god support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and other states to smarten up
stop it stop it cut it out
oh he's taking questions i thought he
wasn't able to take questions unscripted
we are doing that and by the way the
number of people are reluctant to take
it
continues to diminish true continues to
diminish across the country
as they see their neighbors particularly
in communities that have been
very now there's a different group of
people there's a group of people
who've been reluctant because of past
how can i say it past wrongs that have
been done to them
experimentation not sure that they're
being told the truth etc
but then there's another group right
seems to me to be uh
i i probably shouldn't characterize it
but mitch mcconnell keeps speaking to
them
right i give him credit for saying the
idea
he said the polling data shows
republican men particularly young men
don't think they should have to take the
vaccine it's their patriotic right not
to do it their freedom to choose
and he's saying no no take the vaccine
take the vaccine and i'll add a phrase
he didn't but i think he believes it's a
patriotic responsibility
exactly last question
i have not
i i am not look i think the the federal
reserve
was an independent operation right and
starting off my
presidency i want to be real clear that
i'm not going to do the kinds of things
that have been done in the last
administration
he's killing this talking to the
attorney general about who he's going to
prosecute or not
prosecute and under what circumstances
or the fed
telling them what they should and
shouldn't do even though that wouldn't
be the basis upon which i'd be talking
to him
so i've been very fastidious about not
talking to them but i do talk
wow to the uh the secretary of treasury
thank you all very much
mr president uh you mentioned 554 064
american dead from hogan more steve
peters want to know
how this
[Music]
so understand what just happened there
guys
first of all biden just started taking
questions wasn't scheduled to take a
single question but he did
all right um steve peter ducey
yells out so job just back it up for a
second
biden comes out and he says you know
okay he didn't say this but i'll say it
when he took over we were vaccinating
800 000 people a day
we're now vaccinating 3.1 million a day
on the way to 4 million a day we are
about to open by an additional 12 days
we're going to accelerate
eligibility we're on the way to
the majority of americans having a first
shot by may 31st
what a day mr president should the
master's golf tournament not be played
in augusta
come on guys come on
uh so that's steve peter ducey a
complete
complete and total clown um
just a couple other thank yous thanks to
ryan avery
for the website sign up as well as
martin yuri
uh new members number 45 and 46
very well handled by joe biden
really great clips today on the show
including this nearly 20 minute
interview by popular demand with a
quote republican strategist that'll be
out later
members have access to it now and i will
see everybody
probably tomorrow